hello
leader we're um live now thank you
so lovely thank you very much uh good
morning and welcome to the chamber
executive on the
2nd of march um and also welcome to
uh council malone and i think councillor
dawes is joining us as well
uh both of us to speak on a couple of
items um
council malone on the executive forward
plan and also councillor doors
and councillor dawes has also asked to
speak on the item seven the revocation
of air quality management areas just for
note so let's
uh deal with the agenda um apologies for
absence i
think we're all here aren't we trish
there's no apologies leader
thank you very much and uh the minutes
uh of the previous meeting
um our proposed may we take a second
there
so council killing the second are we all
in favor
what does anyone not yeah we're all in
favour that's uh you know
thank you very much uh move twice and
through any declarations of interest
no okay so no no declaration of interest
there
so we moved to the executive forward
plan and uh council loans asked to speak
on this
um counselor malone
hi sorry that we got to that far quicker
than i was expecting
um yes um yeah
it it's the executive forward plan as as
um
pertains to your discussion on the uh
the high street plan
uh now i i asked to speak today after
discussions with the
friends of the alexandria theatre who as
you know have grave concerns about
how the buildings to be dealt with in
regard to the future high street fund
um i appreciate this in the place to
bring up specifics of the council's plan
for the
alexandra but well i'd just like to put
the executive unnoticed frankly that um
my group opposes them and will oppose
them at it at every juncture with the
same tenacity we've opposed over
development
it seems to me that these plans are
proceeding with some indecent haste
it was not very long ago that council
bullavan asked the members of the
cultural quarter group of ons
singular as it was then um for input on
this
and i provided 10 solutions i don't know
whether any other councillor did their
homework on it but
uh i certainly recall councillor bulevan
telling us that there was no possibility
no future and no interest in keeping
alexander to his present format inside
i'm sorry to say i accepted that as
received wisdom and
had it been true then i'd have no
problem accepting the timetable with
which this has been signed off and will
no doubt now proceed on the executive
agenda as you've planned for march
uh however it's not true there's a great
interest and enormous latent sympathy
for adapting
uh the alexander in its current state
and
there's just short of 4 000 signatories
on the petition to preserve it
i didn't know this until recently but i
know that you did
uh i fear that the friends of this
theater have been treated much like the
people of college ward in respect of na3
told that there's a consultation trusted
you invested in the process
only to be cut out of it and ignored
when the answers are not the ones
yeah this isn't a free range of
conversations about the full plan
and pull it back this isn't then a wide
ranging debate
you wanted to speak on the forward plan
and there's an item coming in
march april on the forward plan about
this item so you can confirm your
comments to the issue
rather than a wide-ranging view about
your considerations
on many matters it was a con it was a
comparison that i
felt was pertinent well i don't thank
you so if you could confirm yourself
that would be
helpful okay well let me just say this
then
i mean uh this process needs to be
backpedaled
uh the proposals put forward on this are
proposals that could work while paying
full business rent on a building
now i would ask that you stretch your
timetable to include
full member engagement on this i for one
would like to know what a multi-use
space is and in what town it has ever
worked we
were treated to a three-hour
presentation frankly when the council
fits in low energy light bulbs somewhere
yet
perhaps the most iconic building in
newton now but after the clock tower
is going to be gutted and we've hardly
had a breath of it it hasn't come up in
full council
i think i think i was saying that this
one needs to be signed up
alone you asked to speak on the forward
plan
and what you're doing is talking about
the actual particular
issue in some detail we haven't brought
the report i'm talking about
well you know the forward plan is is the
agenda to which you
you discuss these things oh i can only i
all i can say is that you need to
rethink your
i only need one more
i just want you to confine yourself to a
particular point rather than a rambling
conversation
it's not a rambling conversation
discussing this thing it hasn't come up
in the public sphere
and i and i'm simply putting you on
notice
thank you very much for doing so thank
you if you destroy the alexandra
would not expect to reinstall candidates
from your party
in any scheme and you can kill them
alone
you're not talking about the full plan
you're trying to talk about an item
which will be coming to executive at a
later time
you may want to hold back some of your
comments and views till then
but thank you for your comments believe
me they'll come up again thank you for
your time
i'd expect nothing less thank you
councilman
councillor dawes you also asked to speak
on the forward plan
hi yeah thank you thanks very much and
uh with that i i'll keep it very short
and i won't go into
specifics uh save uh that it was
i wanted to talk about a similar subject
but i think it'd be in the best
interest of everybody to watch the the
budget tomorrow because
uh i know everyone's delighted with
having got the
the funding from government uh it
appears that there's a very large fund
going to be put out for community
ownership of uh business assets pubs
and and cultural assets um and one would
imagine if the strength feeling is so
high we should watch that and be able to
change strategy
relatively quickly based on that and
follow follow the public mood
uh and appetite for such things so that
that's the only thing i was going to
flag so if we could all watch that i
think that would be
very helpful thanks thanks virgin if i
can say yes like you i've heard the
government
if you like trail into the budget as in
all things with
the budget both the one tomorrow and in
previous years i suspect you'll
appreciate
very often it's a detail that sits
behind it so the announcement and then
the detail
and when that follows but i think we'll
all be interested in what
what is coming out both in terms of that
particular issue but
generally in terms of economic support
but should i i agree
thank you for those comments um so
colleagues executive forward planet and
members content that
with a forward plan and and the schedule
and schedule of
reports that are coming yeah okay
thank you very much for that so let's go
on to item six which is the
um increasing the district council's
recycling rate
uh alistair councillor juniors
thank you very much leader uh so uh a a
while back
um you commissioned my service
uh to look at our recycling rates
and what we could do to improve them and
we have produced a report with a
10-point
action plan that that
hopefully we'll see improvements in our
recycling rate
i would like to caveat in the first
place
that that recycling rate is not
the be-all and end-all of uh
of our waste um i i think many in the
industry
consider uh the weight of residual
waste per household uh as
important as as the amount that is
extracted
for recycling so so so that is the first
thing
and we don't intend although we
would very much like to achieve that 60
target um we do not intend
to just chase tonnages uh
for the sake of trying to beat
uh another uh district local authority
uh so we have a system uh
which operates on the basis of curbside
collections
and we ask our residents
to do the sorting for us
so that we can then put the recycled
material
into specific compartments in in the
lorries
on the kerbside this is different to
certainly the top 10 recycling
authorities
who just stick everything into a bin
they send it to a giant shed where
people work in
rather unpleasant conditions sorting it
and there are thoughts in the industry
that perhaps
some are not quite as as honest
in terms of their uh their their
weights and the like uh and quite as
accurate
uh in in their data as we are and
certainly
as we are across the whole of devon so
team bridges
is one of the forerunners of the
combined
um devon aligned system whereby we all
work in the same way there are two local
authorities that are
operating at this very moment in a
slightly different system
uh south hams will be changing to the
same system as us using boxes for
recycling
um in in the coming months and
exeter within a couple of years
so in the report uh colleagues uh there
are ten
ten points here and um
i think in fairness
most of them are things that we are
doing
or perhaps just need ramping up a bit
um some i think we need
uh colleagues to to discuss
uh for instance um
we need to consider the additional bin
policy
uh to remove the the option to to
ask for additional residual bins or
perhaps put a charge in place
for additional bins uh i'm sure we all
know properties where
you you hardly ever see recycling boxes
but you always see
overflowing black bins we need to
consider reviewing the side waste policy
uh we are we offer uh the possibility of
sideways
three times a year um and that has to be
booked
and perhaps we could put uh reduce that
to once per year it's a small amount
um but uh it it it
it would go towards the the totality
and then um i think
effectively the rest um it is is pretty
self-er self-evident uh i would point
colleagues
out to what in my opinion it is the key
uh to to all of that and that is the pie
chart
in there and and the fact that
21.5 of a black bin
contains food waste if we could get that
food waste
out of our black bins we would be the
top recycling authority
in the uk just like that um
so so effectively i'd welcome
colleagues comments um on the report
and and perhaps suggestions to take
part of the report i don't think we need
to take the whole report
but just specific topics to overview and
scrutiny
thank you thank you alistair and chris
brains you're with us
would you like to add anything to what
else has said
um nothing um particular apart from
we do already levy a charge for
additional residual waste bins um
so that would be looking to increase
that rather than introducing it
yeah that was the only thing i picked up
but um
i think the key thing for me is it's not
as we've
previously discussed that the rns
presentation it's not about introducing
additional materials
um or changing the service in any great
way it's about
increasing the participation in what
we're already offering is is key to
rising those rates thank you for that
chris
stephen uh thank you leader yeah a
couple of questions
one is around sort of the education of
people
and i wonder how much we do in relation
to
when the the men and the women come
across a black bin that's full of
stuff that could be recycled do we
actually
sort of softly target that household in
terms of
leafleting or a word about what they
could recycle
and how they could recycle and and the
second point is around
action point seven i i sort of question
additional bins around the district in
view of the
the mess we've seen around sort of
recycling banks where people just turn
up and
dump all sorts of stuff around the bin
so we're not just going to end up with
a sort of a lamp post with a bin
surrounded by a whole load of
detritus that that can't be recycled and
it's going to cost us
quite a bit to sort austin
thank you very much uh leader so in
in the first instance uh if i come to
the the last
bit first uh we we have a policy
on litter bins and um
that i i think that's a policy well it
was certainly a policy that
the last administration brought in um i
don't think
uh i've been looking for it online i
can't
find it i think it's something that we
need to just remind
uh colleagues and and members about uh
because of course
we can't just go around installing
litter bins here there and everywhere
that there is a huge cost we spend over
a million
pounds on cleansing in in the district
and um and as a consequence we
we need to go back to that basic and
ensure that everybody understands
uh that as far as uh people
who who perhaps don't uh operate
uh in terms of their domestic waste
arrangements
we do have systems in place in the cab
for
for recording those properties and our
enforcement officers visit we
we also employ enforcement officers
through the strategic waste committee um
who come around and and and talk to
people
um i think the feeling really is
on that and from the report that
essentially
we we have a small number of hardcore
recalcitrant types and then we also have
new housing estates and and
we are targeting the new housing estates
because
they um as often as not don't understand
our system
and we therefore go out and and explain
to them how
it works and what they need to do and
then finally
in terms of exactly what people
can and can't do i was staggered at a
parish council last week
to discover that no one not one single
person at that parish council meeting
knew that teambridge actually recycled
textiles
so that you you put clothes old clothes
that's a textiles
in a bag put them on top of your
recycling boxes
and we have a specific place in the in
the truck
for that we are a major operator and
our the uh textile re
recycling operation is run for us by the
sally army
uh and and they're the biggest operator
um in
in the uk so we need to actually make
sure that
everybody in the council understands
because
we're important in getting that message
out there and that's why
uh councillor perce i i'd
really like you to take that pie chart
and show it to your parish council and
say look
look look what he's in he's in in
people's black bins
we actually went through a thousand
black bins and and
weighed and measured the contents of
those bins to get that pie chart so
that's a pretty disgusting job
but it's really important that that it's
done
and it's not just that garden waste
because
the textile industry is truly
the world's worst industry for carbon
emissions
there are more carbon emissions from the
textile industry
than all of aviation and shipping put
together
and and most of it we don't wear we just
buy
and on that thought we're just going to
hold that there thank you very much it's
a good point to stop it on uh i hope
that's answered you
stephen could i could i just just
throw in that actually bridgeford does
have its own textile recycling bank
and we make about 50 60 pounds every
couple of months
out of the textiles we sell so i'm
always
there on recycling textiles thank you um
any other comments from colleagues um
one of the things that occurred to me
i'm i'm very keen
i i think we're absolutely right we we
do want to strive to 60 and
uh to appreciate that it's it's about
the incremental
steps to it rather than you know a big
spot to it because that's a goal and
ambition but
one of the things that came through very
clearly in the report was it's not just
about the
percentage of recycling that we do but
it's also about the residual waste
challenges
and the council does very well or the
residents do very well on that as well i
think
so that sixteenth nationally which is
very good isn't it
so that's it there's another thing
actually it's not just about recycling
more but it's about less
residual waste too uh so there are a
couple of
a couple of sort of targets to be worked
towards i was very pleased to be
important
very helpful in setting out a plan
andrew councillor mcgregor
thank you chair um it was just to say i
think we should we should
load the vast majority of our residents
because they do
actually uh recycle and recycle very
well
um and it it's unfortunate um small
number that haven't got a handle on it
yet and
and it is as alastair as uh councillor
dewhurst has said
that uh it's about educating it and
getting cooperation
one thing i took from the report is the
one of the residual sideways
uh elements is that uh we reduce that or
or start charging for it um
my difficulty on that side is that there
are a lot of people from vulnerable uh
households who wouldn't be able to
afford that so where did they where did
they go
so i i think leaving it as it stands at
the moment would probably
be the best thing in my view so that's
that's one thing i would i would say but
thank you very much
all right thank you for that so
colleagues uh alistair anything else or
should we
accept the report the recommendations
thank you thank you
uh leader so so for me i think
i would like to propose that we ask
overview and scrutiny
to do a quick piece of work and and a
within
meeting look at actions eight and nine
uh to to reinforce uh our work there
in terms of uh of our communications
policy
um i've been pushing my in-house
uh team as it were from uh waste and
recycling
uh to to to get to grips with
uh with the the comms that we need to
on this to educate people educate
members
and and certainly that's something very
close to
to to my sort of heart in in terms we
need to understand
and need to know what to do the number
of people who send me
uh emails members uh and
and say there's a bit of fly tipping on
such and such a place
um we that does there's no one on this
council who doesn't have a phone
uh and and it's all there for the doing
uh
on your phone yourself which takes it
right through to the cab
and then finally leader i copied you
into an
email because the great work being done
by
our environmental wardens um and
because it isn't just carrot there is
stick
and and i want people to be aware that
if they go out
and they fly tip they litter
uh in our beautiful in our beautiful
district
that they will end up with a fine and in
fact our wardens have been levying fines
and uh and and also for dog
fouling uh and and i think this is a
really important message that we need to
get out there
i don't want people being pilloried uh
from the nearest lamppost but i do want
people to
understand that if they fly tip
in our district they will get caught
and that's the communication which is to
follow but thank you for uh highlighting
that right now
members contending in particular uh the
uh
referral to overview and scrutiny
everyone agreed
lovely all right no one's against we're
taking that that's fine thank you very
much trish for
we'll agree so we'll move towards seven
which is the air quality management
areas
and cancer adores us to speak on this
item okay it's outdoors
richard are you ready lovely thanks
hopefully i'm the right way around this
time
and um so yeah yeah in terms of the the
air quality
uh monitoring areas i mean it's it's a
sort of
key area that has uh possibly the
biggest
impact on health in uh in the uk
it's a i think it's around a hundred
thousand deaths and
associated illnesses which would be much
higher than that so i think it's an area
that we need not to take lightly
uh i was concerned i i don't know the
detail on the executive but i was
concerned
with the suggestion of removing uh
monitoring areas when
uh i think we should be improving them
the other thing that i
learned when we were looking at
walgreens street
in terms of its impact on on nh3 and we
sought some advice
from uh some pretty high level
uh consultants they they led me to
believe that not only were the
um air quality uh levels poor
they weren't even close and we weren't
even measuring
uh all of all of the pollutants so
um maybe that would be something that i
could helpfully feed back into the
system
uh but but i'd be very concerned if we
start dropping air quality
management areas uh at a point where air
pollution
um is is the biggest health
risk that we have next to covid
all right thanks that uh councillor
dawes uh i'll go to allistair then we go
to david eaton the environmental
protection manager so alastair
thank you very much leader um so
just to uh reply to councillor dawes
firstly
uh this council takes uh air quality
in team bridge very seriously and has
done
for many many years uh in fact i think
there is only one member
uh sitting here maybe two
but certainly one member sitting here
who was actually on the council in the
beginning when we started
to uh monitor air quality and
and thank you for that leader um so you
will see in the papers
uh that that in fact uh uh
councillor connect was actually leader
when air quality management
and air quality monitoring was
introduced
so under the environment act
1995 local air quality monitoring
is a statutory process by which this
local authority
monitors assesses and takes action to
improve
local air quality to comply with
national
air quality objectives so this
is not something that that that we
necessarily do
because we want to do but we do it
because we have to do it
where non-compliance and there is
relevant public exposure there remains a
statutory
need to declare the geographic extent of
non-compliance as an air quality
management area
or aqma in 2005
two such aqrmas were declared for
non-compliance with the national
air quality objective for nitrogen
dioxide
one along idisley terrace in dawlish
and the other along what was at the time
the main road through king's kurzweil
encompassing torquay road and newton
road
since then monitoring for nitrogen
dioxide continued
and from 2016 to the present day levels
of nitrogen dioxide
in both locations have been consistently
year on year well below government
guidelines
this satisfies the government's criteria
necessary
to revoke an aqma the conclusion from
our officers
is that both the aqma for daulish and
king's kurzweil
must now be revoked and as the executive
member for this area of work i
fully support the conclusion
thanks alistair i'll invite david eaton
if there's something to add as well
david thank you leader um just picking
up on councillor dawe's
uh point and question so the um
environment act 1995 that the
legislation is currently under
uh you'll be aware that the environment
bill is currently making its way through
parliament and that's
looking at improving air quality
standards across the board and
specifically
looking at fine particles so pm 2.5
something that we're currently not
obliged to monitor so
part of the proposal you'll see is to
redirect some of these funds into those
emerging air quality issues and
monitoring around our district which may
be in new
or different areas to where we currently
monitor so
that is um you know that's something
that we're aware of
picking up on council doors question
earlier thank you
thank you for that uh david um
and if i'm right on reading report but
and
what you said as to was it's just two
aqmes which were
seeking to revoke that's one indulgent
one in king's kurzweil
because there's been improvement uh and
as david
says that the money that's saved on that
is then going to be used
on on other air quality work
yes that that that is that is the case
uh and uh and and and the specifics uh
around the two uh aqmas are are of
course that
in terms of kings kurzweil um which
uh we we all remember that the days of
uh of of being stuck in kingsguardsville
of the
unbelievable levels of of
well pollution and the like um
were have been effectively cured by the
construction of the 120 million
pound south devon highway um and
i i'm told by uh my local surgery
that uh levels of copd for instance in
king's curse will
have dropped like a stone and that was
the
uh expression used uh by the doctors
i discussed it with um and and i can
tell you that one of our colleagues
lives on torquay road uh and
you can actually see out of our front
windows but
but but that's it there's a nice bit of
anecdotal it would be useful
if by our officers were able to clarify
that with the nhs
and get some data on that it's quite
useful uh
sort of observation i'm going to go to
uh martin cancer wrigley uh thank you
leader
um it's it's excellent news the air
quality particularly indulge
has improved sufficiently so we no
longer need to have the statutory
air quality uh monitoring to declare it
as that area because it is
a tricky spot in italy terrace for those
of you don't remember it's that
bit where you're snaking up out of
dualish where all the buses and the
trucks get sort of stuck because of the
traffic cueing on the a379 there
so the improvement in quality is good
there but the nature of the road and the
nature of the traffic on there
until we have all electric vehicles
everywhere it's still going to be bad
um can i just ask what are what what
we're doing in terms of
ongoing ensuring that we don't fall back
into those levels in either of these
places
clearly king's kurzweil is fundamentally
fixed because of the
south devon highway but duelish is
fundamentally still going to be a
problem until we have electric vehicles
everywhere we'll ask david
david please thank you
so with regard to that i mean there's
there's two aspects i'd just like to
pick up um
from uh councillor wrigley's question so
with regard to electric vehicles
obviously you'll you're aware of the
work that the council is already doing
to support that
um under councillor hook's um specific
area and councillor dewhurst
um the the tenor of the environment bill
is to
to look more towards population exposure
reduction
and that would be a responsibility of
team bridge going forward subject to
that bill becoming an act so that would
require us still to take
action and consideration with regard to
air quality across the whole of the
district
the focus of the legislative power is
within in the aqmas which currently
exists
so that work would continue and every
year as an authority we produce an
annual status report which is on our
website
and that looks at the status of air
quality and emerging areas
within the whole of the district it's
not just on the
aqmas that exist so it's it's it's a
sort of a watching brief for the whole
district not just
um duelish or king's kurzweil subject to
the decision of executive
excellence thank you david appreciate it
uh andrew we go again
thank you chair um it was just to kind
of take up a point that uh councillor
dawes had made
um in respect of walborough and um
one of the uh perhaps considerations
that we should have in future
for all new developments is that there
is
some element of contribution to
mitigations for
air quality particularly around
perhaps provision of city trees which is
a
a modern high technology system which
you know reduces particulates as well as
noxious chemicals from from the
atmosphere around particular hot spots
around a route
that traffic take you know if we take
bitten park road in tin with for
instance that's a really bad
area for air quality the reason for that
is
it's pretty obvious to most people it's
the volume of traffic that's coming
through
in park road heading around towards the
bridge to go to
across the sheldon and to to turkey
further south
and it a way of speeding up that traffic
and not having sitting
for periods of time pumping out um
noxious gases
would be a a solution that would
probably be better in some respects
than simply monitoring how how well or
how bad it's going at this particular
time
so perhaps maybe um we we need to look
at
broader elements to address
rather than simply monitoring and hoping
that we can see more electric cars or
as my preference would be actually
hydrogen cars
all right thank you that so there's a
bit of a curveball there andrew and
thank you for that so what we're going
to do is ask alistair to
give a short reply and then we'll
probably come to david eaton
as well in particular as you've
mentioned it about bitten park road
alistair
thank you very much leader so so the
situation is that
in all three air quality management
areas
uh because king stanton also is one
uh the the air quality has improved
uh and and i think that's an important
uh thing
thing to mention uh over the period of
the
aqmas it has improved uh and
particularly so from from that uh high
point of 2014
uh which was clearly the time when we
were all going around
with hacking coughs and and the like um
the the situation as far as
as what we can do to improve we have had
uh extensive meetings with
uh town councils uh in those three
locations
to discuss exactly what uh
measures we can do to to improve the air
quality in those areas
and um and i'm very pleased to say that
all three
town councils uh were really really
keen and helpful to get on with this
work
and that we are working with them uh to
to help them
come up with with action plans of things
to do
and these action plans can be incredibly
simple
i know that there is one newton abbott
town councillor
who like me is very concerned about
taxis
uh sitting idling with their engines
running uh whilst they're waiting for a
fare
uh and and just a simple thing like
switching off your engine
uh and and ensuring that that happens
um is is really important so we need to
get that message
out there i i was at sheldon fireworks
um
it seems an eternity ago now but but
there was a car
near me that that spent an hour and a
half with its engine running
i asked a police officer and he said he
didn't think he had the power to ask the
person
uh to switch off their engine um but the
reality is
he does and i've taken it up with the
the police and crime commissioner to
ensure that all officers
are aware of that there's a very wide
ranging brief you have ourselves and you
must keep some stuff for future meetings
too
um david um i don't propose to cover
what cancer do you host has already
covered i was going to mention
i was going to mention the engagement
with the town and parish councils that
has been going on
um that action plan is on the executive
forward plan you'll see it on the
forward plan i know you've considered
already in this meeting
to bring forward but part of the work
we'll be looking at those specific areas
and maybe picking up on council doors
and councillor wrigley's points
around wider district improvements we're
currently working with the licensing
manager to look at the hackney
carriage policy and the taxi policy and
how we can use that as another tool
to uh drive improvements in air quality
which would be beneficial across the
whole district rather than specific
locations
thank you thank you so much for that uh
so taking you to the uh
recommendations which are set out uh
our members agreed uh well i'll take it
alistar proposes
we better take a second that uh we'll
take andrew mcgregor as the second all
agreed
yep we all agreed on that one trish
thank you very much
uh and that concludes our meeting can i
say thank you very much
for your time today thank you bye-bye
before we before we go
uh chair um would it be possible to make
a statement about the lockdown
no uh because i wasn't aware of it in
advance andrew
okay no problem all right thank you very
much okay bye-bye